[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hahaha
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mes chers amis d'abord comment vous dire
merci pour votre présence ce soir pour
votre présence si nombreuse qui me
touche profondément qui nous touche
profondément
et vous dire à quel point ce moment que
nous partageons et précieux il est
important nous sommes le 26 avril
nous sommes donc exactement à un mois ce
soir dans cette élection européenne qui
ne réunit ensemble à strasbourg
et c'est une joie de partager cette
soirée avec chacun d'entre vous et je
voudrais vous remercier pour le temps
que vous avez pris pour être ici pour le
trajet que vous avez fait pour cette
soirée que vous consacrez à ce moment si
important de l'élection européenne
remercier en particulier tous nos élus
qui sont ici tous nos élus locaux nous
élus municipaux nos mères nos élus
départementaux nos élus régionaux et
bien sûr nos parlementaires je ne peux
pas tous les nommés ils sont trop
nombreux
mais je voudrais leur dire du fond du
coeur ma reconnaissance pour le temps
qu'ils partagent avec nous ce soir et
surtout pour le temps que chacun d'entre
vous accorde à cette campagne pour les
efforts que vous faites pour faire que
sur le terrain
notre famille tout entière derrière
laurent wauquiez relève la tête car
cette élection européenne a aussi cet
enjeu fort nous voulons pouvoir demain
offrir à notre pays
l'alternative dont il a besoin bien sûr
et notre projet est clair c'est de
pouvoir refonder l'europe pour pouvoir
rétablir la france refonder l'europe
pour pouvoir rétablir la france ce
projet je le porte
avec une équipe magnifique et je suis
tellement touché de la confiance que
vous me témoignez
je ne crois pas contrairement à ce qui
est souvent raconté que cette dynamique
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui soit le
fait d'une seule personne
elle est le fait d'une équipe et depuis
le début de cette campagne
grâce à laurent grâce à toute l'équipe
qui a constitué cette liste eh bien je
partage cette aventure avec agnès evren
avec arnaud danjean qui n'ont pas pu
être avec nous ce soir parce qu'ils sont
partout sur le terrain pour continuer de
porter la bonne parole
et puis avec tous les colistiers qui
nous ont rejoint et je voudrais dire que
c'est un immense honneur pour moi c'est
une joie et c'est une chance de pouvoir
porter cette liste avec cette somme
incroyable de compétences d'expérience
avec ces personnes venues de partout en
france pour représenter notre pays et
pour pouvoir lui apporter demain est
déjà aujourd'hui ce que nous avons de
meilleur pour représenter au mieux ce
que la france peut dire à l'europe
est ce que l'europe peut dire au monde
et je voudrais vous dire ma joie d'être
ce soir ici à strasbourg avec anne and
sander qui représente exactement ce que
nous voulons apporter
anne sander qui est à la fois une
parlementaire reconnue pour sa
compétence pour son expérience pour sa
hauteur de vue et en même temps pour son
enracinement local et la chaleur que
vous témoignez dans vos applaudissements
à anne depuis le début de cette soirée
me fait dire que la politique est belle
quand elle tisse des liens si forts avec
les territoires que nous voulons
représenter tout à l'heure nous avons
parlé longuement avec des agriculteurs
qui m'ont dit qu'ils nous disaient à la
fin de notre échange
à la fin il nous reste au delà de toutes
les raisons de voter pour vous une
raison fondamentale
nous allons voter locale votée locales
dans cette élection global c'est
peut-être ce qui peut permettre à
l'europe de retrouver le sens des
réalités
c'est peut-être aussi ce qui redonnera à
l'europe sa consistance incarné par les
personnes comme anne comme tous les
colistiers qui sont ici avec nous et je
voudrais saluer bien sûr
nathalie isabelle guillaume marie laure
et abdul qui sont avec nous ce soir et
qui représente la france qui nous font
la joie d'avoir fait le trajet pour
venir jusqu'ici ce soir en alsace je
voudrais dire aussi bien sûr amende fait
waeber la joie que nous avons de le
recevoir fait une joie immense que de
partager cette soirée avec vous ment de
fred nous dînions ensemble à strasbourg
il ya une semaine de cela est derrière
ces premiers échanges il y à l'europe
que nous voulons construire qui se
dessine peu à peu
merci infiniment d'être avec nous ce
soir ercis ville comme une manne fred
nous sommes ici à strasbourg dans un
moment évidemment en particulier et
manfred vous l'avez rappelé strasbourg
c'est bien sûr cette capitale au coeur
de l'europe strasbourg c'est aussi ce
lieu où l'europe a montré ses failles et
sa fragilité ou n'aura pas montré
malheureusement sa naïveté
le 11 décembre 2018 cinq personnes ont
été tuées ici à strasbourg par la
barbarie islamiste
cette barbarie qui a frappé il y a
quelques jours encore le sri lanka et
qui fait partout dans le monde des
victimes
cette barbarie qui a si souvent touché
la france qui a si souvent touché
l'europe parce que nous n'avons pas su
faire face à ce danger à strasbourg
l'europe a montré sa fragilité car cet
homme qui a tué
il avait été condamné à 27 reprises en
france en allemagne et en suisse
et c'est bien la démonstration que si
nous voulons que l'europe retrouve sa
consistance et sa crédibilité
il faut d'abord qu'elle retrouve son
efficacité face à tous les grands défis
qui sont ceux de notre temps bien sûr
l'europe nous a donné la paix cette paix
dont notre génération jouit depuis déjà
tant d'années bien sûr l'europe nous a
apporté la paix mais cette paix est un
miracle fragile et nous savons très bien
qu'aujourd'hui les guerres qui se
dessine ne sont pas dieu merci entre ses
amis séparés trop longtemps que sont les
français et les allemands mais que les
guerres de demain
elle se dessine aujourd'hui sous la
forme du terrorisme sous la forme de la
menace islamiste sous la forme de cette
violence qui touche directement au coeur
de nos villes au coeur de nos quartiers
et à laquelle il nous faut réapprendre à
faire face
oui c'est vrai l'europe doit sortir de
la naïveté et il faut nous donner les
moyens juridiques policiers pour faire
face ensemble en renforçant europol en
forçant heureux juste en créant des
équipes mixtes d' enquête et
d'intervention il nous faut faire face
ensemble et je sais que c'est un élément
fondamental du projet que vous portez
là cette menace qui viendra fracturé nos
sociétés il ne servira à rien de se
plaindre de la montée des populismes
si nous n'avons pas su répondre aux
inquiétudes de nos concitoyens il ne
servira à rien de se plaindre de la
montée de la défiance qui touche
l'europe
aujourd'hui si nous n'avons pas su faire
la preuve que l'europe pouvait être un
soutien qui nous renforce
au lieu d'être parfois trop souvent
absente et même défaillante face aux
défis de notre temps
ce sentiment je l'entend partout depuis
le début de cette campagne et je ne
crois pas qu'on le résoudra en opposant
naïvement les progressistes aux
populistes
ce sentiment de défiance
d'incompréhension nous l'avons entendu
cet après midi encore de la part des
agriculteurs qui nous parlait de cette
situation éprouvante qu'ils vivent
lorsqu'il doit faire face à d'énormes
toujours plus lourdes toujours plus
complexes toujours plus exigeante et
qu'ensuite ils voient arriver sur le
marché unique que nous avons construit
des produits cultivés ailleurs dans le
monde qui ne respectent aucune de ces
normes
lorsque nous avons construit cette
europe de la double peine cette europe
par laquelle nous construisons des
règles toujours plus compliqué pour ceux
qui produisent chez nous pour organiser
ensuite nous mêmes la concurrence
déloyale qu'ils subissent lorsque nous
les mettons en compétition avec des
produits importés qui ne respectent
aucune de ces règles
et nous devons répondre à ce sentiment
d'injustice nous devons répondre à cet
écart manqué ressentent tant de français
qui travaillent qui cultivent qui
entreprennent qui agissent et qui se
sentent abandonnés par une europe dont
ils ont l'impression que trop souvent
elles les trahir il faut mettre des mots
là dessus pour pouvoir répondre à ces
inquiétudes
on y répondra pas seulement en insultant
ceux qui doutent
on y répondra d'abord en les écoutant et
en répondant à leurs inquiétudes
alors oui c'est vrai nous notre famille
politique nous proposons de réorienter
en profondeur l'europe pour qu'elle
puisse en se refonde en apporter ses
réponses à ceux qui doutent aujourd'hui
nous proposons par exemple de défendre
une barrière écologique à la frontières
extérieures de l'europe à la frontière
de ce marché unique
ce marché unique nous y croyons il est
l'un des plus beaux acquis que l'europe
est construite mais ce marché unique
doit enfin devenir l'occasion de peser
dans la compétition économique
il n'y a aucune raison pour que nous
puissions continuer de faire comme si ce
marché unique devait être simplement la
proie de tous ceux qui veulent commercer
de par le monde
sans qu aucune réciprocité ne soit
jamais offerte sans qu aucune
réciprocité ne nous soit jamais proposé
nous devons enfin faire valoir nos
intérêts dans la compétition économique
et cette barrière écologique a pour but
d'offrir à travers l'europe
le service que nous devons au monde en
venant rééquilibrer la mondialisation
son principe est très simple il consiste
à faire en sorte que tout ce qui importe
en europe paye exactement les mêmes
contributions que ceux qui produisent en
europe et notamment cette contribution
carbone par laquelle nous incitons nos
entreprises à être vertueuse lorsqu
elles produisent mais il n'y a pas de
raison que cette contribution carbone
fasse perdre de la compétitivité à ceux
qui produisent en europe et qu'ensuite
nous en venions à favoriser une
production écologiquement moins
vertueuses qui fait des milliers de
kilomètres pour arriver jusqu'à nous et
ensuite lorsque nous avons créé ce monde
débridée dans lequel toute l'industrie
se fait en asie
et l'europe devient une terre de
commerces et de loisirs lorsque nous
avons produit ce monde débridée dans
lequel nous produisons des matériaux qui
sont transformés en asie et qui
reviennent ensuite en europe
lorsque nous avons produit cette
mondialisation débridée parce que nous
n'avons pas su défendre nos frontières
et nos intérêts dans lesquels des
agriculteurs voient leurs produits
circuler des milliers de kilomètres à
travers la planète pour être ensuite en
compétition avec ceux qui produisent
selon des standards bien inférieur à ce
que nous nous imposons sans que jamais
on est vu qu'il y avait là dedans
quelque chose de la matrice même du
problème climatique
ensuite nous déplorons que l'europe ne
soit pas crédible mais voilà ce à quoi
il faut répondre
voilà ce que nous devons reconstruire
cette barrière écologique elle doit nous
permettre de faire en sorte que l'europe
devienne un nouveau poumon dans la
mondialisation le poumon d'un nouvel
équilibre qui nous permettra de
réapprendre avec ce marché unique de 500
millions d'habitants à produire ce que
nous consommons à consommer ce que nous
produisons pour faire en sorte que nous
soyons capables d'inventer un nouvel
échange avec le reste du monde
nous n'avons pas renoncé à être défait
dans la compétition économique mondiale
nous n'avons pas renoncé à l'idée d'être
compétitif et de pouvoir marquer le
monde par la force de nos savoir-faire
par l'excellence de nos produits mais
nous voulons pouvoir faire en sorte que
l'europe ne soit pas ce terrain de jeu
qui nous fragilise que l'europe puisse
nous renforcer dans la mondialisation
et c'est tout le sens de cette barrière
écologique faire en sorte que ce qui
importe en europe respecte les mêmes
règles que ceux qui produisent en europe
faire en sorte que demain nous ne
mettions pas ce qu'ils produisent en
europe en concurrence avec des
producteurs qui ne respectent pas les
mêmes règles
c'est la condition nécessaire pour que
notre monde retrouve son équilibre et
pour que nous puissions résoudre ce
problème climatique qui vient ainsi
directement de ce monde de circulation
et de flux perpétuel qui est née de
notre impuissance et il ya là je crois
un enjeu fondamental pour le monde qui
se dessine il ne servira à rien de
continuer d'expliquer à l'ouvrier
français qui a besoin de sa voiture pour
faire 10 km pour aller travailler
que c'est lui qui est responsable de la
crise climatique si nous ne savons pas
faire en sorte que tous ces produits qui
font des milliers de kilomètres pour
traverser le monde
ne sois pas enfin au coeur de ce nouvel
équilibre bref il faut que l'europe
redevienne le poumon de ce nouvel
équilibre que l'europe nous renforcer
trop souvent nous avons l'impression
qu'elle nous fragilise reconnaissons le
sherman fred le problème est aussi très
largement en france bien sûr si nous
voulons que cette voix porte dans
l'europe de demain il faut que la france
redevienne crédible si nous voulons que
la france retrouve son âge et son
agilité sa compétitivité dans l'europe
de demain il faut que nous puissions
renoncer à toutes les sphères
transposition par lesquelles nous ne
cessons d'en rajouter toujours plus sur
les normes européennes
si nous voulons que la france retrouve
sa capacité de rayonner dans l'europe il
faut que nous soyons capables de refaire
de la france
le lieu où nous pousseront les projets
européens plutôt que le lieu où nous
cesserons par une administration
tatillonne d'entretenir une europe des
normes plutôt qu'une europe des projets
il faut que l'europe retrouve sa
crédibilité
il faut que la france refasse pour cela
les réformes nécessaires pour avoir une
voix en europe
et de ce point de vue là malheureusement
la conférence de presse du président de
la république n'aura vraiment rien réglé
la france est pour la première fois dans
l'histoire le premier pays en europe en
termes de déficit public et comment
peut-elle être crédible comment notre
président peut-il avoir une crédibilité
lorsqu'il écrit aux européens pour leur
dire l'europe telle qu'elle devrait se
constituer
comment quand on est le dernier de la
classe peut-on se permettre d'écrire à
tous ses petits camarades en leur disant
vous devriez me ressemblait
il nous faut c'est vrai mais disons le
simplement retrouver un peu d'humilité
dans le débat européen
mais il nous faut aussi retrouver le
sens de ce qu'est ce dialogue européen
dialogue entre amis mais dialogue franc
et dialogue nécessaire bien sûr et nous
avons notamment bien sûr avec nos amis
allemands qui forme avec nous le coeur
de l'europe vivante
nous avons à retrouver ce dialogue a
retrouvé la force et la vitalité de cet
échange qui a fait toujours avancer
l'europe qui doit demain faire encore
avancer l'europe et oui nous aurons
aussi nous l'avons commencé cet
après-midi en parlant de la filière des
betteraviers nous aurons à partager bien
sûr des sujets et qui nous préoccupe ici
en france nous aurons bien sûr à dire à
quel point nous tenons à quelques
éléments fondamentaux de la construction
européenne et bien sûr en particulier
je ne peux pas ne pas le dire ici à ce
siège de strasbourg que nous croyons
être effectivement le coeur de l'europe
bien sûr
strasbourg est sans doute la ville qui a
vécu le plus directement toutes les
folies de l'europe et toutes les folies
récente de la construction européenne
strasbourg est aussi le lieu par lequel
l'europe s'est construit peut-être comme
eu aucune autre ville votre ville a été
celle par laquelle toute la civilisation
européenne et passer ses lois vécu
gutenberg l'inventeur de l'imprimerie
cette première révolution qui a fait
entrer dans l'esprit européen la
diffusion des idées la circulation des
idées
la présence bien sûr d'erasme et dans ce
lieu où nous sommes un amphithéâtre lui
est consacré erasme qui a donné son nom
à ce programme d'échangé européen que
nous voulons renforcer pour que tous les
jeunes d'europe connaissent concrètement
ce qu'est l'europe c'est-à-dire une
réalité incarner erasme qui a été l'un
des premiers à penser l'esprit européen
comme étant précisément fait de cette
articulation féconde entre une
civilisation commune et une pluralité de
cultures qui aurait pu dire il y à
quelques décennies que manfred vous
viendriez ici parler en allemand à
strasbourg dans une europe de paix qui a
pris conscience en fin de cette unité
d'une civilisation qui nous oblige à
cultiver ce lien ce lien étroit dans
lequel se trouve notre avenir
oui strasbourg c'est l'un des coeurs
battants de la civilisation européenne
strasbourg c'est vous l'avez rappelé à
l'instant et nous y tenons tellement
bien sûr strasbourg c'est le signe
vivant de ce que l'europe n'est pas
d'abord un projet mais qu'elle est
d'abord un héritage et c'est sans doute
cela que nous avons oublié
l'europe c'est d'abord une histoire qui
nous projette vers l'avenir
l'europe c'est un élan magnifique
l'europe c'est une vie qui coule dans
nos veines
et cette histoire n'est pas inactuel
cette histoire ce sont les racines par
où peuvent passer les sèves dont nous
avons besoin pour construire demain
l'esprit européen c'est cet esprit de
liberté qui naît dans les cités grecques
et qui s'incarnera plus tard dans
l'humanisme européen qui a marqué cette
ville l'esprit européen c'est le sens de
l'égalité devant la loi devant la
respublica qui mûrit peu à peu à rome et
dans tout l'empiré romain
l'esprit européen c'est bien sûr aussi
celui qui s'est déposée dans la
cathédrale notre dame
notre dame de paris notre dame de
strasbourg de cathédrales jumelles
construite à la même époque par des
hommes qui savait que c'est d'abord dans
une dimension spirituelle que se
constitue le lien qui nous attachent les
uns aux autres dans cet élan vers le
ciel dans cette verticalité d'une
cathédrale qui fait tenir ensemble en
l'air les pierres qui la constituent
nous sommes faits pour cette verticalité
l'europe doit retrouver le sens de
l'idéal qui est en elle
cet idéal de la dignité humaine mûri peu
à peu dans la tradition judéo-chrétienne
oui l'europe ce sont des racines et là
aussi dans les erreurs commises par le
passé sur lesquels nous devons revenir
il y a bien sûr cette erreur immense cas
constitue le fait de ne pas inscrire nos
racines dans les traités européens et la
france
la france disons le en europe la france
avec son universalisme a parfois joué le
mauvais rôle eh bien il faut
qu'aujourd'hui la france soit aux avant
postes avec nos amis allemands avec nos
amis de toute l'europe pour que nous
puissions dans nos traités dire qui nous
sommes les héritiers de cette histoire
qui veulent la prolonger
nous l'avons tous vécu en voyant brûler
notre dame de paris mercredi soir
j'étais avec nos amis tête de liste de
tous les pays d'europe et tous me
disaient leur détresse devant le fait
que notre dame de paris avait brûlé deux
jours plus tôt c'est bien que nous
sommes charnellement dans nos coeurs
dans nos tripes lié à cette histoire qui
est aussi notre présent qui est ce que
nous sommes croyants ou non croyants
quelles que soient nos convictions quel
que soit même d'ailleurs nos engagements
politiques
nous avons tous été touchés c'est bien
le signe que nous avons tous quelque
chose en commun qu'il faut pouvoir
nommer car sinon comment réussir on nous
le défi de l'intégration
comment réussirons nous à accueillir
tous ceux qui dans notre pays tous ceux
qui sur notre continent grandissent sans
savoir se reconnaître français sans
savoir ce que signifie être héritier de
cet esprit européen
il faut pouvoir rpt dire qui nous sommes
et nous sommes ici à strasbourg sans
doute dans le lieu le plus fort pour
redire qu'ils nous sommes dans cette
ville qui je le disais a connu toutes
les guerres de l'europe et qui connaît
aujourd'hui la plus belle aventure de la
réconciliation européenne à travers ce
siège du parlement européen
il faut redire qui nous sommes pour nous
projeter vers l'avenir c'est aussi un
grand européen un grand allemand qui a
fait ses études de droit ici à
strasbourg
il s'appelait goethe sur son lit de
morgen a eu cette parole qui pourrait
être la devise dont nous avons besoin
pour construire notre avenir dans ce
monde inquiétant qui se dessine sous nos
yeux
dans ce monde parfois angoissant dans
les erreurs et les aveuglements que nous
avons connu par le passé et qu'il nous
faut dépasser aujourd'hui ce petit mot
pourrait nous servir de devise mairie
plus de lumière il nous faut plus de
lumière et c'est peut-être là dessus que
nous pourrons construire l'europe
merci infiniment